all right so today we're going to talk
about immunity again and the so this
movie up on the screen here this is a
cell you can see the outline of the
cells kind of around here what's the
outline of the cell but what you can see
is that there's something in the cell
moving around and that is an
intracellular bacteria called Listeria
and you can see it's rocketing around in
the cell it's having a total party in
this cell and what you'll see here is
you can often see the bacteria push out
from the cell so if you look here one is
going to push right now see there are
goes it kind of runs into the edge of
the cell and pushes out and this enables
the bacteria to spread from cell to cell
without actually going into the
extracellular space surrounding the
cells okay so let's take a hypothetical
situation so Listeria is a foodborne
illness it causes a nasty sort of
intestinal disease so Brett do you want
these bacteria having a party in your
cells hell no okay Malik do you want
these bacteria having a party in your
cells hell no okay Carmen do you want
these bacteria having a party in your
cells
hell no yes okay so our body has to have
some way to sort of address this type of
an illness and the problem is if you're
thinking about what we discussed on
Wednesday is all right so you're hosting
this party right this is your cell okay
so you have a host cell that's your cell
and you have an intracellular pathogen
such as a bacteria or it could also be a
virus and they're essentially using
your generous host cell to reproduce
itself to spread to other cells of the
body okay and so you don't want that but
the problem is that I told you about B
cells so remember B cells they have an
antigen receptor it's initially on their
plasma membrane it can also be secreted
okay and it's secreted into the
extracellular space the problem is that
these pathogens are inside the cell and
there's a plasma membrane separating
them from the antigen receptors that you
need to recognize them okay so this is a
presenting issue it's also the case for
T cells yes as you heard on Wednesday T
cells only have this membrane bound form
of the receptor and the antigen
recognition antigen recognition domains
of all of these are extracellular okay
so there's really with just this system
there's no way for your immune cells to
see in the cells so today I want to talk
about how is it that the immune cells
are able how our immune cell is able to
see within the cell in order to address
an infection like this one with Listeria
okay and the first part of the answer is
that it involves a process known as
antigen presentation
an antigen presentation is the process
by which peptides so short sequences of
amino acids right are presented and
displayed on the surface of the cell for
the immune system for immune cells to
see so here peptides
are displayed on the cell surface for
immune cells to see them and in this
specific case is going to be for the T
cells to observe what's going on inside
the cell okay so this this mechanism
involves another molecule which I
briefly introduced is called the major
histocompatibility histocompatibility
complex which is abbreviated MHC so when
I refer to MHC and Wednesday's lecture I
was referring to this major
histocompatibility complex and there are
two classes of MHC s thankfully the
first one is known as class 1 so class 1
MHC and class 1 MHC looks like this like
many of the immune receptors that I've
talked about it has a heavy chain which
is this long polypeptide in blue and
light blue and it has a light chain in
purple okay so the MHC is composed of
these two separate polypeptides they're
encoded by different genes and then it
assembles into this structure shown here
so this Maalik
has to IG domains and these are proximal
to the plasma membrane and this thing is
all inserted in the plasma membrane it's
an integral membrane protein and then
distal to the plasma membrane is this
structure here and if you look at the
crystal structure it's kind of like a
sheet of beta sheet with two alpha
helixes and all together what it does is
it basically creates like a little like
cop okay so it's creating like a cup
okay and what sits in this cup is a
peptide so you get peptides and the
peptides sort of sit in that hand if you
will and some of the amino acids from
that peptide are sticking out and those
sort of displayed away from the MHC
molecule okay so this is basically a
hand that holds peptides and displays
them for the four on the outside of the
cell right so the outside of the cell
here is up this would be the ectoplasm
out here and it's displaying these
peptides for immune cells like t-cells
to observe all right so class one MHC is
a class that's expressed on all
nucleated cells in your body okay so
that's all of your nucleated cells are
synthesizing and a class 1 MHC and then
it's sort of being displayed on the
surface and the peptides that are held
by this class 1 MHC the peptides here
are being derived from a specific place
in the cell which is the cytoplasm okay
so the peptides are from the cytoplasm
so this is the source of the peptides
and I'll tell you how these peptides are
sort of loaded on to this MHC molecule
so the MHC molecule is a membrane
protein so it's translated on the
endoplasmic reticulum and it's
extracellular domain is initially
present in the lumen of the ER okay and
the peptides are from proteins that are
present in the cytoplasm and what
happens to these proteins and this
occurs for you know unfolded proteins
but also for proteins that might be
ubiquitinated is that they're processed
by the proteasome which is this paper
this kind of a shredder like function
for proteins and it cuts up the proteins
into little snippets or peptides that
can then be pumped into the lumen of the
ER through this transporter top so these
peptides can be taken and transported
into the lumen of the ER and that's
where they're loaded onto the class 1
MHC molecule okay but the source of the
peptides is from proteins that are in
the cytoplasm they're processed by the
proteasome so then once you have a
peptide MHC complex it can then be
trafficked through the normal vesicle
trafficking pathway all the way out to
the plasma membrane of the cell where
now that peptide will be displayed for
t-cells to observe okay and so the
peptides here they're processed by the
proteasome process door or cut by the
proteasome
and then the type of t-cell that's going
to look at these class 1 molecules they
are known as cd8 positive T cells okay
so this is the first class of MHC
molecule because there's a class one
that means there also must be a class to
which there is and so class 2 MHC s
are fundamentally different in all of
these properties okay the what the
function shared by these MHC molecules
is they both display peptides on the
surface of the cell okay so MHC
molecules do display peptides on the
surface which is known as antigen
presentation but other than that MHC
class 2 is pretty different you see the
structure of MHC class 2 is very similar
to that of class 1 but you see that
rather than having a heavy and a light
chain here there are two chains that are
roughly of equal size and so these are
encoded by different genes than the
class one molecule and they encode
different proteins but the overall
structural similarity is very similar so
there are two IG domains they're
proximal to the plasma membrane and then
there's this structure at the very end
of the MHC molecule which has this
groove in it which can hold a peptide
that would be displayed on the surface
of the cell
okay and there you see the groove and
you see the peptide that is present in
it all right so one big difference
between class one and class two is that
class two is expressed on a much more
restricted set of cells okay so and
class two MHC s are expressed
specifically on specialized cells
is antigen-presenting cells and these
antigen-presenting cells include cells
like B cells which are the ones that
I'll focus on but also phagocytic cells
that can phagocytose foreign substances
phago say phagocytic cells and there's
another cell type called a dendritic
cell which is also an antigen presenting
cell I'm gonna focus on the B cells
right so class 1 is expressed everywhere
class 2 is really expressed on these
professional antigen presenting cells
okay and the way that the peptides the
source of the peptides and the way
they're generated is also very different
so peptides for class 2 come from the
extracellular space and they are
processed by lysosomal proteases
so by lysosomal proteases and so I'll
show you how that looks in cartoon form
so so for MHC class 2 the peptides are
from the extracellular space and so
we've talked about ways that cells can
take in material one way is through
endocytosis right so if this is my
antigen the antigen could be endocytosed
by the cell okay and now it's in a
vesicle that's present in the cell and
so if you endocytosis protein then it's
now in a vesicle and one compartment
that it can go to is the lysosome where
are these there are these lysosomal
proteases that can then chop up this
protein into little snippets or peptides
and so MHC class 2 again it's translated
at the endoplasmic reticulum like all
plasma membrane proteins and so but in
the endoplasmic reticulum you see that
peptide groove is blocked such that
peptides derived from the cytoplasm
can't interact with class 2 ok
but then it's trafficked to a unique
compartment which can combine with the
compartment that has the polypeptides
that originated from outside the cell
and then those can get loaded on to this
class 2 MHC molecule and then this can
be recognized by t-cells but in this
case it is a endocytosed my chalk I need
to get it back here so in this case it's
not a cd8 T cell that's recognizing it
but a cd4 positive T cell ok so let me
briefly review what I just went through
and review the differences between class
1 and class 2 so class 1 MHC is
expressed on all nucleated cells whereas
class 2 is much more restricted being
expressed specifically on antigen
presenting cells the T cells that
recognize these two classes are
different class ones recognized by cd8
positive T cells class 2 is recognized
by cd4 positive T cells ok and the
source of the antigen is different in
these two cases the source of the
antigen for class one is the cytoplasm
for class 2 its the extracellular space
ok so the different MHC s are sampling
different sort of pools of proteins and
the where the peptide is loaded is
distinct between these two which allows
these distinct classes to basically
discriminate between the sources of the
peptides that they're loading so for
class 1 that's in the ER for class 2 it
arises from a vesicle compartment that
we
results from endocytosis of an antigen
from outside the cell all right now the
type of molecule that recognizes this
MHC peptide complex is the t-cell
receptor which I briefly outlined on
Wednesday but now we're going to talk
about it in much more detail so the
t-cell receptor or TCR and I talked
about its structure which is shown up on
the slide but I'll just draw a more
simply here if this is the plasma
membrane this is the cytoplasm and this
is the EXO plasm facing down then this
t-cell receptor has two chains one is
called the Alpha chain and the second is
called the beta chain and each is
comprised of two IG domains which you
see up there right so the T cell
receptor here is in pink you can see an
IG domain there on one strand IG that
domain there so and you have another two
IG domains on the other subunit and this
receptor the t-cell receptor recognizes
antigens through its variable domain
which is here and it's binding basically
to the end of this receptor okay so this
is a sort of ribbon diagram of a
structure for a t-cell receptor the
plasma membrane would be up here this is
the end of the t-cell receptor and MHC
is in green and is holding a peptide
here in yellow and you can see how the
TCR is sort of interacting or docking to
this MHC peptide complex so for the
t-cell receptor to interact and bind to
MHC the t-cell you have to have a t-cell
receptor that recognizes the specific
conformation of the peptide
that is being sort of extended away from
the cell right so let's say this is my
t-cell receptor and I'm going around and
searching for cells that might want to
look at this then if I had a t-cell
receptor that was like this right it's
not going to be able to stick to this
MHC peptide complex however if I had a
t-cell receptor that had the right
confirmation because there are different
types of t-cell receptors it might be
able to dock on and stick to the peptide
and then the t-cell is now stuck to the
peptide MHC complex okay so there are
different t-cell receptors there's a
diversity of t-cell receptors and
they're able to discriminate between
different peptides loaded onto MHC okay
so now we have to think about where this
diversity of t-cell receptors comes from
there's a diversity of TC RS and lucky
for you the mechanism that generates the
diversity of TC RS is the same that
generates diversity for antibodies okay
now Georgia asked a really good and
really important question at the end of
lecture on Wednesday which is she asked
if this sort of rearrangement of gene
segments in the variable domain if the
antibody was due to splicing or
recombination at the genomic locus and
the answer is that it's recombination at
the genomic locus okay and that's very
important point so here's a diagram for
the beta chain of the TCR you can see
that like the b-cell receptor there's a
gene rearrangement in the genomic DNA
that brings VD and J segments together
to make the variable chain of the t-cell
receptor okay so like the b-cell
receptor there's a gene rearrangement
also known as vdj recombination and this
is not splicing of the transcript this
is in the genomic DNA okay the very
important point because by having this
happen in the genomic DNA right it
creates an irreversible change in that
genomic DNA such that all subsequent
cells that are derived from that
original B or T cell are going to
express the identical B or T cell
receptor okay so it's not splicing but
it's a real sort of irreversible change
to the genomic DNA okay so you we have a
diversity of T cell receptors but the T
cell receptor is not the only thing that
enables the T cell to interact with
whatever cell is presenting the antigen
there are these other Co receptors which
are important so there are Co receptors
on the T cell this is on the T cell and
the cone receptors are cd4 and cd8 and
they're expressed on different subsets
of T cells okay and these Co receptors
because it's not sufficient for just the
T cell receptor to interact with a
specific peptide it's it also requires
this co-receptor in order to get an
immune response okay so the logic is
that if the T cell receptor and the
co-receptor both bind to the MHC then
you get a particular type of response so
you need both okay and cd4 cd4 cells
recognize the class 2 of MHC
cd8 recognizes class 1 MHC okay so you
have these two different subsets of
t-cells and they recognize these
distinct MHC complexes so my question
for you is what should the cd8 positive
T cells do and to help with that you
might want to look at where the peptides
are coming from from that are presented
on the class 1 MHC s which are going to
be presenting specifically to cd8 okay
so what should these do what what what
does it mean if you have a class 1 MHC
molecule containing a peptide that looks
foreign well where do the peptides come
from what's that Patricia Patricia is
right they're coming from the cytosol so
if you have foreign elements coming from
the cytosol what might that mean for
that cell good bad irrelevant what's
that what's that okay Brett saying it
needs to be dealt with and I totally
agree
here's one scenario would be the
scenario I showed you in the beginning
of class where you have some sort of
intracellular parasite that is basically
using the host cell for its own evil
purposes to produce more viral viruses
or more bacteria okay so so if this the
immune cell has some sort of indication
that this is going wrong another example
is in cancer right because if you have
oncogenic mutations in certain genes
then those could be recognized as
foreign and so an appropriate response
might be
to do something to that cell that would
limit the expansion of the tumour or in
the case of an intracellular parasite
you really need to terminate the cell so
that you stem the tide of viruses that
are going to be produced by that cell
okay so the response should be to kill
okay so if a cd8 positive see if you
have a cd8 positive T cell it indicates
there's something wrong inside that cell
and the response should be to kill it
okay
and these cd8 positive T cells are known
as killer or cytotoxic T cells okay so
what happens if the cd8 positive T cell
recognizes a ma MHC class 1 peptide
complex then it releases materials from
inside it that perforate that cell and
lead it to undergo cell death okay so
it's a way of limiting an infection by
killing the cells that the virus or
pathogen is using to reproduce itself
okay what about cd4 positive what should
be the response of a cd4 positive T cell
should it also kill should be like the
t1000 no one gets my cultural references
yeah
should it be the Terminator - no what
yes sir who thinks that should terminate
okay Steven can you tell us your logic
what why why should it not terminate
[Music]
what are the MHC class 2 cells yeah it's
not only a B cells to B cell that
recognizes like the foreign agent that
you're infected with yeah Brett they're
they're binding something that it
recognizes is foreign internalizing it
and then presenting bits of that for an
element on the outside of itself the
vessel but that is shooting the
messenger exactly yeah so it would be an
extremely bad idea for the cd4 positive
T cell to kill what's presenting the
antigen because you would kill the exact
cell that you would need to fight that
antigen right here you have a B cell it
would be a B cell that's producing an
antibody that actually can produce
antibodies that might be able to
neutralize that foreign invader and so
you don't want to kill it you want to
help it or enhance the B cell function
and so these cd4 positive cells are
known as helper T cells and they enhance
b-cell function in a number of different
ways oh I should point out where this
happens so this sort of interaction
between B and T cells happens in the
lymph node okay because in the lymph
node you have antigen presenting cells
or even soluble antigens coming in to
these lymph nodes and you also have B
and T cells and this is kind of like the
B and T cell like hang out to like get
sort of like interactions between these
two distinct immune cell types okay and
when you get sort of a B cell that
presents an antigen that's recognized by
a t cell then the T cell enhances B cell
function and it does so in a number of
different ways the first way is that it
induces a response in the B cell known
as affinity maturation and this affinity
maturation results from a hyper mutation
of the variable domain of the antibody
such that you get even more diversity
and such that a B cell can be selected
that even has a tighter binding to the
antigen okay so for affinity maturation
this is responsible for the transition
in binding from well more weak binding
to a tighter binding which I talked
about as being a difference between the
primary infection and the secondary sort
of immune response okay so the
antibodies get better because of this B
and T cell interaction and this affinity
maturation process one other thing that
happens is that the B cell can produce
different classes or eisah types of
antibodies and this is known as isotype
switching
and so this is again the genomic locus
for the the heavy chain of an
immunoglobulin you see here's the vdj
segment so it's undergone vdj
recombination and then what you see are
these different blue regions here each
of these are exons that encode a
different isotope for the antibody okay
so the first one is Moo and so that
produces IgM when that's the one that's
proximal to the vdj so if you have AG
and that's the initial state of the
antibody and that's this initially
membrane bound and serves as the B cell
receptor and then but each of these
different constant domains even though
they're not undergoing variation they
have different effector functions and
can do different things for the body
okay so for example if you had isotype
switching and you had a recombination
event that brought this gamma two
segments together with vdj that would
produce the isotope which is known as
IgG an IgG is a highly secreted form of
the antibody and it's highly effective
for bacterial infections okay because
it's secreted in the blood okay and it's
able to neutralize bacteria and limit
the infection that way but there are
other possibilities because you have all
of these different possibilities and so
you could get vdj together with this
alpha and that would produce a nice ax
type known as IgA an IgA promotes
mucosal immunity because it's able to
pass through the epithelial linings in
addition I GE is another type of
antibody and the constant domains are
constant for each of these isotypes but
they recruit different effector
functions
okay so I Gigi would be hitting bacteria
by promoting phagocytosis of those
bacteria IgE in contrast is especially
good at dealing with worms right so if
you have it like a intracellular or not
intracellular but a like an intestinal
worm or something like that then I GE
its effector functions are better at
dealing with that okay so this processes
of isotype switching sort of allows the
immune system to adapt to tackle a
particular type of pathogen all right
the last thing that the last way in
which T cells enhance this function is
by promoting the differentiation of
b-cells into different types of b-cells
one of those types of b-cells is known
as a memory visa b-cell and the memory P
cell is a b-cell that can last in the
body for decades even if the the antigen
is not present okay so this mediates
sort of the memory of the immune system
and so just to summarize what I just
told you so if you have a b-cell and it
recognizes an antigen which could be a
protein it would internalize that
protein via endocytosis and then process
it so that it can display peptides from
that antigen on its surface and if
that's recognized by a t-cell then that
leads to an interaction between the T
and B cell that will lead to these
different things happening such as
affinity maturation isotype switching so
the red here would be a different
consonant chain on this same variable
chain so the variable chain doesn't
change with the isotype switching so
it's still always able to recognize that
antigen is just recruiting different
effector functions okay and you can also
get differentiation of b-cells and to
plan
the cells which are really secrete a ton
of antibody and therefore help the body
fight infection okay now this is
important because for a vaccine to be
effective you need to engage this t-cell
response such that you have all of these
things happening so all of these things
need to happen for an effective vaccine
so for an effective vaccine you can't
just activate the humoral side of the
immune system you have to activate both
the humoral and the cell mediated sides
such that they interact in order to
enhance the immune response all right
now I'm going to move on and talk about
a big problem that the immune system has
which is that it needs to somehow be
able to discriminate between
self and foreign right and so if you
have your immune system recognizing an
antigen that is natively part of your
body that results in an autoimmune
disease okay so there's a balance of the
immune system between tolerating
antigens or attacking them and if it's
attacking a native antigen then it's
autoimmune okay and this is a huge
problem if you think about it because
we've talked about the b-cell receptor
the antibody and the t-cell receptor
right our bodies are generating tens of
millions of these receptors that are
diverse and can recognize different
molecules okay so our body's generating
tens of millions of antigen receptors
and it does this constitutively so that
means that it's just doing it
automatically you don't even need to be
infected for this to happen this is just
part of the development of B and T cells
okay so it's constitutive doesn't
require infection constitutive in
addition is totally random right now
your body could generate sort of any
sort of combination of VD s and J's and
it can mutate in a certain way that it's
likely that at some point during your
lifetime you're gonna generate a
receptor that recognizes a native
protein in your body so it's totally
random at least what the sort of the
rearrangement of the vdj gives you okay
that process is constitutive and random
okay so I just want to point out several
diseases that are caused by autoimmunity
and I've distinguished them based on
whether the disease involves the
generation of antibodies that recognize
self or t-cells that recognize self so
for antibodies there's a disease
myasthenia gravis which in individuals
individuals generate an antibody against
a receptor for a neurotransmitter
acetylcholine okay and acetylcholine is
the neurotransmitter which is
predominantly involved in sending
signals from a motor neuron to a muscle
and therefore antibodies that inhibit
this receptor result in muscle weakness
okay now self antibodies can also result
in diabetes and individuals can develop
antibodies that recognize and inhibit
the insulin receptor and this leads to
insulin resistance and diabetes mellitus
okay some examples of t-cell mediated
diseases are if you recall back in the
beginning of the month when we talked
about electrical signaling in neurons I
told you about the myelin sheath and how
this increases the speed of the action
potential
that axon and if T cells attacked the
myelin sheath then it disrupts this
process of electrical signaling and that
results in a devastating disease which
is multiple sclerosis autoimmune disease
involving T cells also involves diabetes
and if T cells attack and destroy the
islet cells of the pancreas this also
disrupts the body's ability to produce
insulin and that results in type 1
diabetes
okay so I I'm sure many of you know
people with these types of diseases and
they're obviously of significant impact
both in this country and around the
world alright so the problem for the
cells in our body in the immune system
is that we have the immune system has to
have some sort of way to distinguish
between self and foreign okay so how is
it that the immune system does this and
also it has to have different responses
to self recognition versus foreign
recognition so what should the immune
systems response be if there's a self
recognition what should it do to the
cells that recognizes the need of
protein Rachel
[Music]
it could delete that cell right what
rachel says you should get rid of it
right and so one way to think about this
process is there's a bit of a Darwinian
natural selection going on in the body
and if there's a self recognition then
there should be a negative selection
against that cell so there should be
negative selection this cell should be
more unfit whereas if there's if it's
obviously foreign then there should be
positive selection this D cells should
be more fit okay and what Rachel's
suggested is to get rid of the cell
which is a great idea because if you
kill off the cell then you won't
generate any more cells that have that
recognition against self
okay so negative selection is mediated
by apoptosis and cell death and positive
selection could be both the activation
of the cell and also its proliferation
okay as you see up on the slide there
that orange cell right if it was
recognizing a foreign antigen would get
activated and would undergo a monoclonal
expansion all the cell's resulting from
that expansion would express the same
antibody and therefore recognize that
antigen okay so this would result in
cell division or expansion of that
population of cell
so now we have so that tells now we know
what to do with self versus foreign but
how is it that we distinguish between
self and foreign ok so how does the
immune system distinguish self from
foreign and there are several mechanisms
to do this the first is that the organs
the lymphoid organs where these B and T
cells mature and undergo these genomic
rearrangements are largely protected
from foreign agents okay so the there
are basically only self antigens in the
generative lymphoid organs these are the
lymphoid organs where B and T cells are
being generated so the generative
lymphoid organs will be the bone marrow
for B cells and the thymus for T cells
therefore if a B or T cell if its
receptor engages with something very
tightly during its development that's a
signal for the for the immune system to
delete and kill off that cell okay so if
you get self recognition here you get
apoptosis and deletion of that cell the
second way that the body is able to
distinguish is that it responds to
antigens specifically when there is an
innate immune response or this response
better when there's an innate immune
response
so you can think of it like a
coincidence detector right if you have
an immune cell and it recognizes an
antigen and there's also an innate
immune response that's a strong
indication that this is foreign so this
this would indicate foreign to the
immune system okay if there's antigen
only and the body is not amounting an
innate immune response is much more
likely that this will generate a robust
immune response and this is the immune
systems signal that this is a self
antigen okay this is also important for
vaccine development because in most
vaccines in addition to having some
antigen that's a part of the infectious
agent there's also something called an
adjuvant which is basically something
that activates the innate immune system
okay so the adjuvant activates the
innate immune response and that's
important because if you just had the
vaccine with just the antigen there
wouldn't be nearly as robust a response
okay so you need both to activate the
adaptive immune system but also the
innate immune system to really get a
robust response so I want to end by
talking about this year's Nobel Prize
work and it involves another mechanism
that basically prevents autoimmunity and
down regulates the activity of these T
cells and that involves another type of
we've only talked about activating
receptors on the T cell right the T cell
receptor cd4 cd8 they're activating
receptors for the T cell receptor but
there are also inhibitory receptors that
are on the surface of T cells
so inhibitory was calling receptors one
is called ctla4 and another is called PD
one PD one okay their names are not
terribly important but what they do is
they keep the immune system in check
okay and we've talked a lot about
signaling and how signaling gets
activated and often a step in signaling
is once you get the signal sent and it's
been sent there's like a negative
feedback that then turns off the signal
such that their signal termination right
so you often have some type of signal
termination that way you don't have just
a constitutive activation of the signal
which in this case would be sort of
inflammation in an immune response and
one or both of these is involved in sort
of keeping the immune system in check
and stopping it after you get that
initial reaction okay now the reason
this is so important and why James
Allison and tasuku Honjo won the Nobel
Prize is they had the idea to use this
as a therapy for cancer okay and it
turns out that Kent some cancer cells
can express the ligand for these
inhibitory receptors such that they can
avoid the immune system from recognizing
the tumor okay so if this this would be
one case where the tumor cell is
expressing the ligand for PD one and
that inhibits the function of this
t-cell receptor so that it doesn't kill
the tumor cell and that leads to the
expansion of the tumor so the tumor can
expand in an unchecked way and what
James Allison and tasuku Honjo
determined is that if you block that
inhibitory receptor then you sort of
uncheck the response of the immune
system such that these immune cells are
now able to recognize the tumor cells
and kill them okay
so by by sort of blocking the inhibitor
you now have T cells these are cd8
positive T cells that are killer cells
they will now recognize these T cells
and kill them off okay so you basically
there's what's known as an inhibitor
blockade because you're blocking the
inhibitor and this is these are
inhibitors are antibodies that recognize
these inhibitory receptors and they're
now being used to treat some forms of
advanced cancer and so this is something
that the cancer field and the immunology
fields are both really excited about
what might be one complication with this
type of treatment if you get rid of the
inhibitory receptors and what might be a
consequence yeah Steven yeah you get
autoimmunity that's exactly right
so one of the downsides of this is that
one of the side effects is that you can
have patients with an autoimmune
reaction so it's not the magic bullet
but it's a step in the right direction
all right we'll see you next week
you